don't get your expectations
too high yeah which is which is what we
have to watch out for because we meet
you know jessica
julia and she's good looking and she's
nice to you
and so you take that trajectory of the
first two data points that are both
pointing up and you just turn that into
freaking an angel yeah you know what i'm
saying with a future with a future
with kids like the whole nine yards you
have two data points yeah
one she's cute
two she's nice to you at that moment
you take those two data points and run
freaking buck wild yeah for a female you
take a dude he's a handsome dude
and he's nice to you there's two data
points
and you're going thinking that this is
it this is this is the one do not do
that
gather more data you can you observe
yeah right if you're looking if you if
you're walking up to a
um
a cave and you thought there was a lion
in there right
are you gonna do you want to gather some
data like you see some let's see you see
some
lion scat
outside right sir hell yeah let's see
you see some lion prince outside you got
two data points could there's there's
seems like there's a lion in there
do you go running into the cave looking
for the lion no you don't
so let's not do that here
let's stay outside the cave gather more
data points without running into the
cave is my recommendation
here's another thing and this is kind of
along the same lines people aren't who
you want them to be
they are who they are
and you can't confuse those things and
you can't think that you're going to
take someone who is the way they are and
change them in to who you want them to
be
now how do we not get hurt i'll tell you
how you don't get hurt
when you stay outside collecting data
points you don't over commit when the
lion comes out or the lioness comes out
with its mouth dripping with blood and
you see it from 200 yards away through
your binoculars you go oh cool good to
see that now i didn't lose my larynx
you know what i'm saying sure now i
didn't get my head slashed apart
so when you see when you get to see
someone when you get more data and you
realize that someone isn't who you
thought they were you go oh cool i'm
glad i didn't invest a bunch of time
money commitment effort into this
relationship when all that would have
happened is i would have gotten my heart
ripped out and eaten yeah
walk away don't look back don't be a
jerk about it
but say hey
jessica it was awesome to know you i
really appreciate it look you know i'll
see you out sometime
then walk away and don't look back
what we do is we look back what we do is
not we just look back we start walking
back we crawl back we see if they're
looking we try and get their attention
it's a freaking disaster
walk away don't look back
sounds like a song you might be writing
but you're well here's the thing this
very well could be a woman by the way a
female
yes and i i'm kind of talking from the
male perspective yeah because
i'm a male yeah yeah
and as i was wondering like well you
know what's different for it's not it's
actually not i don't think it's any
different yeah i think it's the same a
woman should do the same thing look if
the relationship is worth it and it's
meant to be
and i hate to say that because it sounds
super cheesy
but if it's meant to be
it you'll be good and that's like a big
thing that goes along with your data
point
theory hypothesis whatever is like you
know because the big thing and let's
face it we we know a lot of navy seals
and
there seems to be i don't know one data
point they're going and here's the thing
no they they get a bunch the ones i've
known anyway some of the other they get
a bunch of data points and a lot of them
are red flags but they seem to just you
know bypass those red flags and just
look at maybe the one or two good data
points or whatever and then they base
the future on that or whatever yeah well
okay so here's a good addition to my
comment yeah gather more data points
and read them
and and utilize them in the calculus of
your
forward movement
because you're right
i've seen some of my friends
man you see
mega red flag data points
there's one awesome data point which is
oh she's beautiful yeah oh yeah that's
the data point
and then the other data point is she's
psychotic
she is an alcoholic
she is from uh
uh insane background
her environment is crazy
and what's the guy think yeah dude i'm
little married oh yeah exciting
you meet a
hot girl mm-hmm and they're super hot
and they're impressed that you're a navy
seal right
we're kind of going in the right
direction hell yeah and kind of a big
deal you know like i mean you know guys
with jobs that they like regardless of
sealed nut seal you can go you're i
don't know stock broker and someone's
impressed with that oh you kind of want
to get get you know you want to be
around that that little environment
right my wife
i told my wife was in the navy when i
met her which was true
and
she didn't seem to be impressed with
that at all
maybe after a little while of knowing
her i was like well i'm in the seal
teams and she was like oh
well and that's what i found too and
this is i don't know i don't know
everybody you know and i can't read
minds to be honest with you we figured
that out last broadcast but
it did seem like how you throw the butt
you constantly say you're not a mind
reader but you always throw a button but
i see behavioral patterns but this is
just in my experience and i don't know
everybody like i said i don't know
everybody i'm saying for what it's worth
this is my experience then my
interpretation or misinterpretation i
don't know
where
girls or groups of girls like if they
know what a navy seal is and they like
it they're impressed by it
they'll be around
and girls who don't know what navy seal
is it's like okay you're military it's
either military non-military to them and
they don't know like probably your wife
was
they're not impressed with it they're
just like whatever cool you have a job
so that's the the reason they'll be out
but the people who do know what it is
the girls who do know whatever it is oh
they love that thing they're using the
jargon or whatever and it seems like
there's little groups of them that's
what it seems like you're correct there
are yeah so
i'm saying if you cut if i'm a navy seal
and of course i love being a navy seal
and i go and i come across one of these
groups and i see one of the hottest one
in the group and she's impressed with my
impressive job and she's letting me know
that's a point pleasure for me so we
have a data point one of the many yes
sir a very pleasurable data positive a
data point that gets calculated within
20 seconds oh yeah what do you do
so that's what i'm saying data point
calculated check rock and roll yeah yeah
maybe not maybe try to uh uh be on the
lookout for those red flags yeah and
look man i think i really kind of summed
it up it's like go slow man don't over
commit right go slow yeah go get crazy
you know and and to your point which is
difficult is that you're like that kind
of ruins it
right because we like to be oh oh
yeah jessica it does
it's like no dude she's not so great she
might be yeah but just take it easy dude
i don't know when yeah it's the risky
run for sure you know because the you
know the the better it can be
the worse it can be
and then if you dumb it down to like hey
i'm gonna take my time and detach and be
like less emotional or whatever like
don't you kind of put a limit on the
goodness of it
it's
weird because it's like you're out at
sea at a storm in a storm and you want
to catch some of those big waves when
you're out there but you want to be safe
when when you're you don't get smashed
and drowned either sure which so it's
like this weird balancing act you gotta
you gotta kind of have a big one too is
people they try to force stuff to you
know like oh i'm thirsty they and this
person indicated their age like around
30 right where that's kind of the time
right where people are starting to be
like oh i'm not in a relationship you
know all this stuff and then they start
actively searching for a future husband
and wife you know a bad move that's what
i'm saying
just actively searching is a bad sign
and people can smell intent and now
you're on the whole totally wrong path
don't do that yeah we should have that's
a good good catch yeah so don't force
that kind of stuff don't be like hey
let's meet my parents on like the second
date or whatever the thing is everything
we're saying
everything we're saying is in support of
that because if you're out looking for
if you're out look going into the cave
they are like what are you doing to my
camera right now are you doing that
what are you doing no one invited you in
here no knock freaking no knocking
rolling into the cave no
so don't go you know sit back use your
binos
your binoculars
look at from a distance
stay away by the way guess what's going
to happen they're going to come out
looking for you because they're
interested and now you have a little bit
of a better advantage yeah right you're
not looking stupid
no that's bad to look stupid so i don't
know kind of gotta let it happen
naturally you ever have a friend who
tries to force it for like they try to
accelerate the friendship like quicker
yeah dude people don't really do that
with me yeah i could see how that can be
for sure
but you know guys people do that
sometimes you know it's like oh i'm new
to the town or whatever
hey you wanna
anyway you gotta let that stuff develop
naturally that's what i'm saying
i used to feel like you were kinda like
that
[Music]
see what you're doing right now this
makes me not want to hang out with you
kind of want to go home
you